[Music]
on this tuesday night ontario's new
pandemic projections
what's ahead for winter and how much of
a wild card is omicron we must always
keep our guard up what's needed to
control another covid spike it took me
24 hours to get tampons delivered to my
room conditions for those stuck in
quarantine hotels i told them like look
i don't have locks on my door one
strategy that could be cheaper for the
government and just as effective
two presidents two hours of talks one
topic joe biden fires a warning at
russia's vladimir putin
and instagram's new safety tools for its
youngest users i'm mostly on my phone
hashtag protection or pr gimmick
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as scientists keep working to understand
the omicron variant there are
indications in south africa it may cause
less severe outcomes than other forms of
the virus but it is spreading fast and
there's still not enough data to be
certain of anything in ontario today the
latest projections about covet 19 show
case counts will keep rising and that's
without accounting for omicron in the
worst case scenario ontario could have
three thousand you covered 19 cases a
day by next month because of vaccines
hospitalizations are not projected to
rise as fast there are 165 patients in
intensive care now that could rise up to
400 driven by unvaccinated people
it saddens me deeply to see the vast
majority of individuals in our intensive
care units
they're unvaccinated they never took
advantage of the means to protect
themselves
if the numbers do rise it will strain
the health care system again and what
the impact of omicron might be remains a
wild card eric sorenson has our top
story tonight
it's not what anyone wanted to see one
ontario region windsor is reimposing
restrictions starting friday indoor
gatherings of no more than 10 people
restaurant capacity just 50 percent the
fear is the province could descend into
another covid winter coveted cases have
risen steadily since november projected
numbers will only level off around a
thousand cases daily if there are new
public health measures like fewer
contacts with current behavior cases
could reach 1700 a day in january and
that's if half of all 5 to 11 year olds
get their first shots by the end of this
month if fewer kids are vaccinated daily
cases could approach three thousand but
add in the omicron variant then even if
half the youngsters get shots case
numbers could shoot up to two thousand
or three thousand depending on omicron's
severity the emergence of omicron serves
as a stark reminder of just how quickly
things can change and how we must always
keep our guard up while ontario hospital
icu admissions are stable for now the
modeling predicts a rise to 300 or more
with current behavior and that's not
accounting for omicron's impact that
will put more strain on hospitals and on
staff that prospect comes as ontario
plans to lift proof of vaccination
requirements in businesses next month
things are changing and we've got a
system that works when pressed the
ontario health minister was not prepared
to change course yet no one in the world
knows how this is going to turn out but
once we do know we will be giving people
sufficient information in order to
understand what we need to be able to do
pressure could mount not to lift
restrictions in the dead of winter what
happens in january and february are
often the most
active time when it comes to respiratory
virus outbreaks so i do i was surprised
about that date i suspected to be pushed
back though a full lockdown may not be
necessary i don't think we're going to
see you know lockdowns um for a number
of reasons including political ones
because look we have the tools to
control this but so many unknowns lead
us to believe that yes we're in a
precarious position the best defense
against another coveted winter is for
kids and the unvaccinated to get their
shots and for everyone else to get their
boosters eric sorensen global news
toronto
the federal government is trying to ease
some of the confusion about travel rules
including the use of the arrive can app
it has been mandatory for travelers
entering the country but after hundreds
of complaints that the app is unreliable
and awkward to navigate the public
safety minister has instructed border
services officers to show leniency
people will now be able to provide
information at the border in person
that is little relief though for the
people who have already wound up in
quarantine hotels even though they met
all the vaccine requirements and had a
negative test
heather urex west reports
wow come on mom
for the last four days tiffany gora and
her two young daughters have been
staying at a federal government
quarantine hotel in calgary the canadian
family lives in egypt and had come home
to calgary for christmas but the omicron
variant changed everything there's a
security guard on every single floor you
cannot
you know even step foot outside of your
door gora is among a growing number of
canadian travelers raising concerns
around how these hotels are operated she
says it's been difficult to access basic
necessities you can't get
anything that you need you have to it
took me 24 hours to get tampons
delivered to my room
janet game from edmonton spent 40 hours
without anything to eat after the public
health agency that operates a toronto
quarantine hotel failed to provide food
safe for her to eat she has celiac
disease you would think these people
will have some idea about what it means
to be a select person or
to be sensitive or food allergy for
jhumi ogunshula a producer with global
news radio who recently returned from
visiting family in nigeria there was
also a problem with security the first
thing i wanted to do after moving my
boxes in was to lock my door
and then i realized you know the latch
at the top had nothing to hook onto we
put the measures in place to protect
canadians we have to buy ourselves some
time to learn more about omicron but not
all public health experts agree that
government quarantine hotels are the
best way to proceed it's much cheaper
for me to do uh
antigen tests on a daily basis than it
is for me to stay in a hotel room
which is probably which is probably as
effective so i think
there needs to be a rethinking of that
three of you gora and her daughter spent
72 hours waiting for their pcr results
to come back they all tested negative
but are still waiting to find out when
they can go home heather urex west
global news calgary
there is some promising news from the
company hoping to become canada's first
producer of a covid19 vaccine quebec
biotech firm medicago and
glaxosmithkline say their phase 3
clinical trials found the two-dose
vaccine to be 71 percent effective
against most variants of covet-19.
omicron was not included it wasn't known
about when the trial was conducted
this is all based on a press release
from the company the results need to be
scrutinized jamie morocco reports on the
preliminary findings and where the
canadian-made vaccine is at in the
approval process
made from these little green weeds
quebec based medicago says its coven 19
vaccine is ready for a green light from
health canada it will be the first
canadian based vaccine for covid and it
will be the world's first
plant-based vaccine for human use of any
kind the plants are used to create
virus-like particles that resemble the
structure of the coronavirus because it
looks like a virus the immune system
responds very well to it over the last
20 months medicago has studied 24 000
research participants half received two
active doses of their vaccine and
medicago reports its shot offered
overall protection of 71 percent that's
well shy of pfizer's 95 vaccine efficacy
or modernist 94 but still offers
positives the efficacy is not
unreasonable
especially because the efficacy in most
these vaccines is usually much greater
in preventing
sickness as opposed to just preventing
the disease
completely medicago says immunity even
jumped when it came to variants
including delta and gamma but kovit's
newest mutation omicron wasn't in
circulation during the trials experts
say without more vaccines more mutations
of the virus are likely it's not just
about
canadians getting more vaccines but what
can we do globally in terms of having
our own supply medicago says it will
make submissions to health canada
imminently if approved it would become
our fifth vaccine and at least 20
million domestic doses are assured but
in a country where nearly 81 percent of
people already have one dose the company
agrees global distribution is a priority
less than one half of the world's
population has had access to vaccines so
far so that's there's still billions of
doses that are needed doses it hopes
will be homegrown by 2023 jamie morocco
global news toronto
the former head of personnel with the
canadian armed forces is facing criminal
charges vice admiral hayden edmondson
has been charged with one count of
sexual assault and one count of indecent
acts military police announced the
charges today before handing the case
over to the civilian court system
edmondson has been on indefinite leave
since march after cbc news reported he
was accused of raping a subordinate
officer on board a navy ship in 1991
that allegation came just weeks after
exclusive reporting by global news on
allegations of sexual misconduct against
other senior leaders in the canadian
forces edmondson has denied the
allegations
the federal government is reintroducing
legislation to lift mandatory minimum
penalties for minor drug offenses and
some gun related crimes the move is
designed to reduce the
over-incarceration of indigenous and
black people in canadian correctional
facilities
there's a general understanding that
all mmps do is reduce is increase the
number of people you put in prison it
doesn't reduce crime doesn't reduce
recidivism
and has a negative impact on your
ability to to treat problems in the way
they should be treated
if passed the legislation would allow
judges to have greater use of
conditional sentences such as house
arrest in cases when there is no threat
to public safety police and prosecutors
would also have to consider alternatives
to prosecution for simple drug
possession such as addiction treatment
programs
a delegation of about two dozen
indigenous leaders planning to meet the
pope at the vatican later this month has
postponed their trip the spread of the
omicron variant has made them reconsider
the timing of the visit the head of the
assembly of first nations announced it
at a special chiefs assembly today
abigail beeman was watching it abigail
bring us up to speed
donna the special chiefs assembly is
happening virtually across several days
this week and in her opening remarks
national chief roseanne archibald
dropped some news the trip was planned
for the week of december 18th but now
has been postponed out of concerns over
the threat of the new covid 19 variant
the health and well-being of our
delegates their families and communities
is paramount to us a delegation of up to
30 indigenous people including elders
youths and residential school survivors
as well as some canadian bishops were
set to head to the vatican later this
month and meet pope francis this was
supposed to happen ahead of the pope's
expected visit to canada a date has not
been set for that trip the indigenous
community is hoping the holy father will
issue a formal apology for the church's
role in the residential school system
the trip was to include private meetings
for the pope to hear directly from
residential school survivors in a
statement issued late this afternoon the
group said they will reschedule to the
earliest opportunity in 2022 and it
notes the risk of infection and changing
situation makes for too great a threat
for elderly delegates and those who live
in remote areas getting a full and
complete apology from the holy father is
very important on the path to healing
and closure so it's sad that they're not
going but their their health and safety
is obviously the number one priority
minister mark miller also spoke at the
virtual assembly and took questions from
chiefs not very happy with the federal
government including this man who lost
his home in the linton bc fire
nobody from the feds of the province
replying to our emails if we're writing
to you and your staff please write back
we have to be doing a better job with
with our partner in bc but also uh but
most importantly with you on the ground
uh how the how we deal with uh with
dealing with emergency management miller
also referenced the government's
announcement that it will turn over
twelve thousand records to the national
center for truth and reconciliation
tuesday the nctr announced more
collaboration this time from the
missionary oblates of mary immaculate
the oblates ran 48 residential schools
in canada including those in cowissus
and takumloops where unmarked graves
were found the oblates will give the
nctr full access to residential school
records in the archive in rome although
it's not clear what may be within those
records donna all right abigail beamon
in ottawa thank you high stakes talks
between two world leaders coming up
america's stern warning to russia about
ukraine
[Music]
the american president has said there's
no substitute for direct dialogue
between leaders and today joe biden had
a rare meeting with russian president
vladimir putin u.s officials describe it
as direct and straightforward with no
finger wagging the u.s and other nato
countries are deeply concerned about the
massing of rushing troops near ukraine
jackson proskow reports on what the two
leaders discussed and why it matters so
much
good to see you again facing an
increasingly tense standoff over ukraine
u.s president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin spent two hours
engaged in intense talks he told
president putin directly that if russia
further invades ukraine the united
states and our european allies would
respond with strong economic measures
we would provide additional defensive
materiel to the ukrainians and we would
fortify our nato allies on the eastern
flank with additional capabilities in
recent weeks russia has amassed an
estimated 100 000 troops near the
ukraine border along with tanks and
artillery u.s intelligence believes
putin could be preparing to launch a
full-blown invasion as early as january
this build-up is concerning to us it is
still not
entirely clear what mr putin's
intentions are the issue is ukraine's
place in the world
russia wants assurances that the former
soviet state will not be allowed to join
nato or even cooperate with the western
alliance
the u.s has refused to accept such
demands biden says he fully supports
ukraine's sovereignty i'm not sure putin
really wants it part of russia so much
as he just doesn't want it part of the
west on top of promising additional
military aid the u.s has warned any
invasion would trigger severe economic
sanctions against russia moscow could be
cut off from the global financial system
but that has not deterred putin in the
past and some experts believe the
military buildup is simply a ploy
designed to make cooperation between
ukraine and the west seem too risky it
makes ukrainians perhaps want to join
nato more but i think it makes other
nato countries want to invite ukraine in
less
because we realize what that would mean
it would mean the possibility of war
against russia though neither leader
seemed to budge in their position the
white house did describe the
conversation as direct and
straightforward a sign perhaps that
diplomacy may be an achievable path to
warding off conflict
jackson prosko global news washington
there's a new development in the
investigation into the 2018 killing of
saudi journalist jamal khashoggi
one of his suspected killers has been
detained the first international arrest
in the case he's believed to be a
33-year-old former saudi royal guard he
was detained at turkey's request at
charles de gaulle airport in paris he's
one of 26 saudis wanted by turkish
authorities in connection with the
killing khashoggi an outspoken critic of
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
was murdered inside the saudi consulate
in istanbul an investigation by the u.s
concluded the crown prince ordered his
murder the saudi regime has denied any
involvement and said the killing was a
rogue operation by a team of agents
facebook's parent company is facing a
nearly 200 billion dollar lawsuit for
allegedly helping to fuel the rohingya
genocide in myanmar the class action
lawsuit was filed in the u.s by rohingya
refugees legal action is also being
taken in the u.k lawyers accused
facebook of failing to stop hateful
anti-rohingya content on its platforms
they say facebook algorithms gave
priority to hate speech and made the
violence worse according to the u.n at
least 10 000 rohingya muslims were
killed in myanmar in 2017.
facebook has not yet responded to the
allegations
wild weather the intense storm taking a
swipe at parts of ireland and the uk
a powerful storm is hitting parts of
ireland and northern ireland bringing
heavy rain strong winds and snow it
knocked out power to nearly 50 000 homes
and businesses this afternoon video from
this remote lighthouse shows the size of
the swells in the atlantic ocean wind
gusts have topped 112 kilometers per
hour
and hawaii is under a state of emergency
now as residents brace for what could be
catastrophic flooding an intense winter
storm called a kona low is pounding the
hawaiian islands with heavy rain and
high winds the hardest hit regions could
get close to 300 millimeters of rain
mudslides down trees and power outages
have already hit some areas and rock
ledges along a maui highway look like
waterfalls residents have been asked to
avoid travel until the conditions
improve
next why instagram wants users to sign
up to log off
[Music]
there's a new mystery on the moon these
images from a chinese lunar rover show a
cube-shaped object off in the distance
that looks like some sort of hut
it could just be a rock but china's
space agency is moving the rover closer
to get a better look that could take up
to three months for now speculation is
swirling on social media maybe it's a
lunar fast food hut
others say it looks like star trek
villains making their debut
well with jokes like that it's easy to
get sucked into scrolling through social
media we all know how hard it can be to
put the phone down
now instagram has launched a new feature
to help encourage users to take breaks
it's a pop-up notification aimed at
minimizing harm to productivity and even
mental health as ross lord reports not
everyone is giving it a thumbs up
it's a rare day when john hogg and his
daughter isabella can spend time
together away from their phones and her
favorite mobile app instagram i use it
quite a bit
i'm mostly on my phone if i'm not at my
sports i watch her when she's on too
long and i'll remind her that you know
there's other things to do but
it's
it's the way the world is right now it's
hard it's hard to manage it now there's
a new tool that could nudge instagram
users to back off
it's called the take a break feature
newly launched in the uk ireland
australia new zealand the us and in
canada users need to opt in first and
considering instagram profits from the
dopamine driven fixations of more than 1
billion users some social media analysts
are skeptical they're positioning it as
you know we're looking after your
wellness we care about you
maybe they do but the evidence has not
shown that to be the case facebook
consistently chose to prioritize its
profits instagram facebook and their
parent company meta are being called out
for ignoring their own internal research
about harm their platforms can lead to
especially among teenagers the take a
break launch comes a day before
instagram head adam moseri takes his
turn before u.s lawmakers his blog post
says early next year instagram will
launch more tools allowing parents and
guardians to see how much time their
teens spend on instagram and set time
limits
pr exercise or not john and isabella say
more reminders can't hurt i think it's
brilliant i think that if i have the
reminder i'll be like oh i actually have
been on it so long and so i'll be able
to do my homework instead of
procrastinate on my phone still looking
for a solution and the struggle to
loosen technology's ever tightening grip
ross lord global news halifax
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's york
canada is a beautiful sunset near milden
saskatchewan we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you